Creating a level sequence is a straightforward process and there are three methods you can deploy.
By using the main toolbar and the Cinematics Clapboard button, you'll create a new level sequence,
place that level sequence icon into your level, and it will open the level sequence in Sequencer for you automatically.
The next option is using the plus add button in the Content Browser.
Browse up to the Cinematics option and choose Level Sequence.
This will create a new level sequence, only place it in the Content Browser where you specify,
and not immediately save the level sequence to your hard drive.
The final method is simply right-clicking in the Content Browser and creating a level sequence in the folder you're currently viewing in the Content Browser.
Like the previous method, Unreal will create the level sequence, but not immediately save the file.
Whether or not to add a level sequence to your actual level is a matter of choice.
If you do, they'll appear in the level as a clapboard to give an indication to other teammates working on your project
that this level sequence is tied to a particular level.
Selecting it and seeing the details in the Details window will allow you to open the level sequence and do other additional tasks.
Once a level sequence has been created, you can populate Sequencer with Skeletal or Static Mesh Actors, Lights or Cameras,
and provide animation sequences to your actors and keyframes on control rigs and transform tracks.
Fade tracks are also available to fade in and fade out of your sequence from any color you choose.
Right-clicking over the fade track will bring up the Properties field to set various attributes, or you could use the Select Details menu.
With all of this information, you're armed and ready to start creating something amazing.
Let's move on to our next module where we'll conduct a practical exercise.